cette semaine vous avez peut être aperçu
devant le théâtre de 50 ans caméras et
projecteurs mellick tir artistes saint
quentinois tourner le clip de sa
nouvelle chanson mon ange je souhaitais
faire un film avec une vraie histoire
dans le clip et on va dire on a tourné
toutes les parties du film justement
bâtir le playback musique maintenant
avec toutes les captations musiciens et
mellick tir composent musique et paroles
ils jouent plusieurs instruments et un
sur la voie sur son nouvel album
disponible dès le 1er octobre je me
sentirais quand même de trois musiciens
mais c'est vrai que j'ai écrit les
paroles j'ai composé la musique et j'ai
joué à peu près tous les instruments son
album aussi basse batterie guitare piano
synthé et puis j'ai fait appel un
violoniste aussi qui s'appelle monsieur
romano voilà qui m'a fait tout ce qui
était violent qui on en sait mélanger un
petit peu au niveau des styles j'ai
essayé de rassembler un petit peu tout
ce qui était musicien du classique du
rock du jazz pour faire un petit peu
cette fusion des écoles une fusion
musicale pour un résultat variété pop
rock ou les chansons d'amour se
succèdent c'est une grande histoire
d'amour cet album d'une façon je pense
que pour écrire des textes il faut
c'est du vécu c'est du ressenti oui
c'est des histoires façon tous les
chanteurs et chanteuses racontant
revient ça fédère toutes ces histoires
qu'on a vécu quoi l'histoire d'une vie
celle de mellick tir artistes une
courtois qui a débuté le chant à l'âge
de 9 ans aux côtés des poppys il
s'essaie en temps à la comédie mais sa
grande passion reste la patrie à
laquelle sont l'oncle a initié
aujourd'hui mérite hier soir un nouvel
album où il chante avec sa fille
décidément pour l'artiste la musique est
une histoire de famille